[Music]
hello hello and welcome to denver
colorado
hey john
if i was to say eu
where in the united states of america
is denver colorado and say for instance
i was to say that america was the shape
of my hand yeah put your hand up let's
have a look
right tom yeah is that the right yeah
florida
is
could someone switch on dom's mate he's
very upset and very quiet
hello hello
can you hear me at the back
good
can you hear dom
one two one two we'll go wireless all
right i can't stick that in there if you
want oh yeah or maybe you don't want it
no no no no no
so as i was saying though yeah go on try
to be casual with it
i'm out of breath from giving up giving
candies yeah
um
your hand your hand your hand america
yeah cool
florida
new york yeah
california
where
is denver colorado
it's because i get a chance to point
this time instead of you being far away
i'm gonna say denver's about
there
[Music]
i've done it you're getting better at
this yeah yeah i've been brushing up on
my american geography
have you been um cheating no there's no
cheating involved but we are going uh
soon we're going to uh
boston
yeah yeah
toronto
no
no canadians nope gonna need to brush up
on those places too well guys thanks for
coming this is the third
uh friendship onion podcast and it's
getting bigger and bigger each time we
do it so thank you for that
it's very sweet you're very loyal guys
yeah we do
we love you all equally except for
people with the merchandise who we love
a little bit more yes yes yes nice
merchandise yes nice and and the uh vips
who are sitting in the front row who
paid extra special money
of course
it's all about cash at the end of the
day isn't it bills like they're late for
us yeah so we're in denver well as you
guys uh saw we're going to be doing a
classic denver dish
um
eating at breakfast lunch and dinner a
staple
uh the jolly rancher which we'll get to
later we tell you all about that i just
found out that they do a jolly rancher
gummy version that isn't that's not the
classic jolly rancher is it no
it just it's they've rebranded it
nonetheless we'll be talking about that
we'll be doing that too but when it
comes to billions on eat the world but
before we do that should we do a little
bit of uh housekeeping
peeling the onion
how much fun are you
to keep my house so clean and true
where's she going
get back in here get your position
she's going for a refund you won't get
your money back there's no no refund
once you're in this room you've paid
that's it lock the doors
really a question here go on dom from uh
jacob s
in aspen
aspen colorado very close to us lovely
stuff yeah that john denver's full of
shooters etc
lovely movie
jacob said wondering what y'all
think of genesis been getting into it
for a while their 2007 live album
definitely seems on the print side of
things now
i was confused because i thought it
meant the first book of the bible
ah well
i'm a fan
fire brimstone
first there was nothing
and then and there was light right but
he's not talking about that he's talking
about the band
pete
pete somebody peter gabriel peter
gabriel
collins
what do we think what do you think about
genesis though um i'm actually not that
well versed on genesis i like some of
peter gabriel's work sledgehammer do you
guys know that sledgehammer video
revolutionary video at the time
incredible that he was you know became
like a roller coaster and a fruit salad
stop action fruit salad
um and phil collins arguably one of the
coolest bald men out there
i love i love phil collins and you know
what i loved about phil collins as well
as his music no jacket required i just
removed my jacket
as a preamble to that album
and uh
also i really liked his acting
buster
yeah i thought it was brilliant yeah
anyone seen the movie buster
i would if you haven't seen it one guy
has there you go
my god
it's phil collins
hiya phil
uh about the great train robbery wasn't
it boss yeah it was great for one person
who had his skull fractured well that's
a tragic deal yes not too great but yeah
he's good that phil collins yeah all
right well that's a great question from
jacob s and then there's another one
here bill's directly underneath dylan f
from denver colorado um don't do the
hand thing we've already done we've done
that but uh john johnny clues who helps
us in the uh
in the podcast help help is a loose term
though
we're trying to get me join us on these
but he's he's a very busy man and he
doesn't care about us really yeah
but we asked him to find some questions
from colorado and he did he's done well
though yeah he has he's done fantastic
have you guys looked at the upcoming
league of legends
mmorpg that is being made and will you
guys consider playing it well dom let me
just start by saying
i love league of legends yes
is it
as a show of hands who plays league of
legends out there are quite a few people
now have you guys been playing league of
legends for a while or is this something
that you were introduced to via the
friendship onion real quick
[Music]
league of legends update let's do one
actually because we played two games the
other day i was heimerdinger billy's
always heimerdinger
try to get him to play someone else but
he's so good at heimerdinger that he
just won't do it but i wasn't good
enough that we didn't lose both games
you got slightly beaten up by by a bully
yasuo didn't you yeah it did um
i was playing um
you were a misfortune the second was
misfortune and locksmith but we we lost
terribly we played great individual
games but we had a terrible jungler who
didn't get any dragons and by the time
we realized we had a terrible jungle the
enemy team had four dragons which means
we were in real trouble and then we just
couldn't uh get ahead could we
all the people in here that don't play
this game have no idea
but i quite enjoy that i quite enjoy
going quite deep yeah i like it just to
see people like what it's a deep dive
but i'm not
mmorpg well
role playing game but anyone out there
massive multiplayer
online a massive multiplayer online
role playing game i thought that's what
league of legends was what's the
difference
what what is the difference
anybody know silence
then i would have to say to dylan f from
denver colorado dylan you're not in here
are
you no
dylan i hate to say it but we don't know
what it is and we don't know what it and
we know we've never thought about
playing it well why well why don't we
end on a positive note and say he says
will you guys consider playing it why
don't we say well consider it i will
consider playing that yeah i'll consider
playing that too good uh bill from
colorado in denver said i was listening
to the latest podcast i had an idea
about one of the allowed curses in the
film brilliant so bear with me guys says
with a terrible cry
the balrog fell forward and its shadow
plunged down and vanished but even as it
fell
it swung his whip
and the thongs lashed and curled about
the wizard's knees
dragging him to the brink
he staggered and fell grasped faintly at
the stone and slid into the abyss fly
you fools he cried
and then
into the darkness
[ __ ]
quite good actually
quite good that's quite good
for those of you that don't know who
don't listen to the podcast the uh this
came up because dom
recognized that it was a pg-13 yes which
means you're allowed one swear
swear word so we've been trying to put
one swear word then he'll order rings
that would be perfect and the great
thing about that one
that means the second movie
would start with gandalf still going
yeah so you could maybe get a two for
because that wouldn't count it would be
from the first i think i still like the
one that still seems to be the
unbeatable one for me is
when mary and pippin
are at eisenguard maybe a little
inebriated on uh
mead or cider or ale and a little bit
too much pipe weed and gandalf the white
turns up for the first time with gimli
and legolas and aragon and they all kind
of say some stuff and under gandalf's
breath in the film
he goes hobbits and i think it'd be
great if he goes [ __ ] hobbits
just a little subtle just a little bit
thrown in there type thing
ah the sound that makes me smile it's
the sound of another sale on shopify the
all-in-one commerce platform to start
run and grow your business shopify gives
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big businesses so upstarts
startups and established businesses
alike can sell everywhere synchronize
online and in person sales and
effortlessly stay informed shopify
believes in liberating commerce for all
because entrepreneurship has the power
to drive communities forward and
commerce can be a force for good scaling
your business is a journey of endless
possibilities and i love how shopify has
the tools and resources to make it easy
for any business to succeed from down
the street to around the globe like mine
shopify powers millions of businesses
from first sale to full scale reach
customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and many more gain insights as you grow
with detailed reporting of conversion
rates profit margins and beyond shopify
is more than a store connect with your
customers drive sales manage your
day-to-day more than a store shopify
grows with you this is possibility
powered by shopify go to
shopify.com all lowercase for a free
14-day trial and get full access to
shopify's entire suite of features grow
your business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
onion right now
shopify.com slash onion
let's listen to a voicemail maybe from
colorado this is elizabeth
i'm from white plains new york
that's about 45 minutes um from
manhattan
um it's about an hour by car
and uh 45 minutes by train
but anyway my question to you both
is what does it mean
when they say principal photography
i've always wanted to know what that is
i've been listening and watching
the
appendices to the floor of the rings and
to the hobbit and that comes up a lot
love the show so much i hope you can
answer this question thank you
i just love you guys oh sorry
sorry lesbian that's a good question and
and i like that we got every type of
travel yeah
takes this long from train if you take a
tram another 12 minutes more take a bite
that's an hour and five if you've if
you've got it yet four hours
you're there
but it's a great question principal
photography because actors will talk
about principal photography quite a lot
as opposed to things like pickups or
re-shoots so william what's principle
well principal photography is the big
main part of filming
where
in in
big
productions light loader rings
um
uh
pirates of the caribbean
uh godfather
jaws
yeah they get it again oh yeah big films
that
they pretend they're going to film
everything that they need but they don't
they need pickups sometimes or they need
reshoots where they fix things or when
they put it together they're like oh
it'd be great if with a close-up of
someone there but principal photography
is
you're coming from the 12th of january
to the 14th of march for principal
photography so in the appendices when
we're talking about oh we shot that in
principle photography but then we did a
pick-up
a year later that's what we're talking
about and principal photography for
lauder rings was about a year and a half
which is unheard of for a movie because
it was the first time they'd done three
movies basically as one film i know why
are you telling me i was there i know
hello tell those look do you know what i
did there i get lost in your eyes
they're quite amazing thank you what
color are they know
they change every morning just a like a
blue but a beautiful like a mix don't
look at him too much don't look at him
too much
um and and i i'll i'll continue on with
what billy said i think the reason why
we we as a cast talk about principal
photography so much is because
most of the time on a film you'll do
principal photography and then you might
do
a 10 12 day pick up shoot which is
neither here nor there people don't tend
to talk about it when we were doing our
pickup shoots it was months wasn't it we
would come back after principal
photography the next year for months and
then for two towers for months and
return the king so i think that the cast
and crew wanted to make it how clear it
was that
one thing was in 2000 but sometimes we'd
be filming in 2002 and that's a big
difference in all of our lives you know
yeah and that's why everyone in louder
rings wore a wig
because they couldn't take the chance
that you know
viggo will get a haircut or
you know
somebody gets scalped or something yeah
yeah gr and great wigs in lord the rings
as well do you know what i mean they are
fantastic wigs the world's best
film wig maker peter owen and his
partner peter cook made these incredible
wigs i mean you very rarely see
the little piece of lace and i think
most people that talk to me just assume
that that was my hair i wish i could
grow hair like that i really i don't
know yeah
but um yeah so everyone wore a wig which
was incredible you know it's a
an amazing amount of work
um we did have other voicemails but it
just suddenly came to me dumb why are we
doing voicemails when there's people in
the room what a great question
why don't we just take a couple of
questions from people in the room and do
we have a oh do we have a mic as well do
we have it
you've got it now i'll go because yours
broke do you want to go out i can go i
can i've already been into the fray to
give out jolly ranchers
you can put it on that mic stand if you
want it or you can't go into the audi
there's a gentleman over there yeah who
put his hand up very quick hang on sir
i'm on my way right on your way then use
the steps because my bloody knees is
that beyond borg underwear you've got it
it is expensive yeah
beyond bog made more money from uh
boxers shots and uh
watch it
boxer shorts and socks than he did in
his entire tennis playing career
well there's an incredible fact that
you've learned here on the friendship
onion live hello don't touch the mic for
god's sake hello sir what's your name
and where did you come from cameron
we're from denver
you are two people always come with a
person
you never know nowadays
she him then that time you know
okay cameron you said what's your
questions so i just wanted to say thank
you both for being here it's really
awesome that you guys showed up and we
all loved lord of the rings so much so i
just want to say thank you from
everybody here i'm sure so my question
is thank you
all
right
[Applause]
what was the most unexpectedly difficult
part of the filmmaking process of lord
of the rings okay okay billy so that was
cameron yeah cameron from denver
colorado
and he wanted to know what he said what
was the most difficult part of making
the lord of the rings trilogy well for
me it was uh the exhaustion it was so
tiring like we worked
always six days a week sometimes seven
and it took three hours to become a
hobbit every morning so if we were
filming it you know eight in the morning
we'd be picked up at 4 30 in the morning
before doing a full day's work and then
an hour to take off
all your hair and feet so for me
i was just really tired um a lot of
people were very tired you were i wasn't
and this is interesting because
um
we all did medicals throughout lord
rings whether we had an ailment or just
in general just to make sure they were
okay
and i was told
at the start of filming that i did not
produce a normal amount of melatonin
in my body which i believe is uh
i'm going to say peptide
and raise my voice when i say it because
i'm not sure if it's actually a peptide
then i would
could be an amino acid or a protein does
that does anyone know
hello
peptide peptide
which what creates the peptides the
brain is it the brain brain produces
melatonin when you when the sun goes
down and you're getting ready to sleep
type your brain does it your brain
creates you know only organs create
chemicals
so not the brain then that's why it's
that's what why you know an organ is an
organ there's another fact you've got
here there you go
onion i do think it's the brain anyway
the doctor said not a problem you're
okay it's not a big deal but he did say
to me at the time do you do you rarely
feel tired and i said that's true
actually i don't really feel tired and
you know that being my mate i don't feel
tired too often do i which is kind of
annoying because when you feel tired it
doesn't let you sit down or anything you
always want to do something i think also
what billy's getting at here is when i
invite people over to my house for movie
night
it is actually movie night like i want
people to sit and watch a movie and
maybe enjoy a snack and a glass of wine
it's not come over and fall asleep on my
couch tonight
but which is which all my friends do
and i'm like well i've seen this i i
could be watching something else you're
just sat here asleep next to me well
then as your guest i would like to say
is watch the movie night not watch me
watching the movie night oh yeah well
good point well i don't know what was
what the hardest thing for me was making
lord rick's i had a blast um
i obviously don't know i can't think of
anything was actually quite easy it
wasn't easy
but
i i did not have a tough time making
those films i suggest that was when uh
mary and pepin swell oh right yeah and
then you knew you couldn't hang out i
could say that i could say see that yeah
because there's a great camaraderie
between um billy and i
seated to my left
and uh when when i found myself in
different parts of new zealand it was
quite sad and it was that time where
mobile phones or cell phones as they say
here we're only kind of just coming in
so we didn't we were emailing each other
and that was about it wasn't it yeah
right any other questions a very fast
hand went up there go on john i'm on the
way i'll be back bill yeah
another flashy or beyond box there
lovely
hello my dear lovely cap oh what what's
your name and where did you come from my
name's lorraine and i'm you're from las
vegas nevada which is uh yeah 10 hours
uh
west of here by car two hours by plane i
think roughly
lovely stuff listening love that
um i just had a question for you i read
a wonderful article um who came on the
new york times uh in december about the
trilogy and just what it means to women
specifically it's become i think a
heartwarming film for women to watch
during christmas especially it's kind of
like their die hard if you will
um but yeah it was just about kind of
the enduring power of the male
characters of lord of the rings and how
they make women feel safe and i was just
wondering if you guys had any thoughts
about um i noticed a lot of young women
especially um have been getting into the
trilogy i'm posting on tick tock about
it and i just was curious for your
guys's thoughts about
yeah what the hobbits in particular um
mean to young women and and uh the
enduring appeal of
male protagonists who uh yeah women feel
very safe turning to and uh yeah just
would love to hear your thoughts on on
that women women let's talk women
fantastic subjects very very good that's
a very good question because i think
as i remember it um the studios had got
it completely wrong
they were pitching the movies at 14 year
old boys i think
you know that
pete
didn't care what the studios were saying
anyway you know he was making the films
that he wanted to make and we were there
to support his um vision of that
but i think they were surprised
at the
huge following that and oh that's so
nice
she's following um the films got from uh
women middle-aged women younger women
and
i i would love to be able to talk to
that but i can't really other than
i think tolkien
spent his life creating a universe
that was incredibly deep and rich and
and full of goodness you know in many
different ways and i think the hobbits
are almost the epitome of that they're
almost the heart
they're like humans but without any
cynicism without
you know you there's not the subtext
they are
you know they're there they're friends
they they tell you how they feel and
whether
women want that i don't know
i think we all want that in some way but
yeah it's funny that you did notice that
because i noticed that when the movies
come out
yeah i think it's great that it appeals
to everyone and that it's been coming
back for different generations it's
fantastic here that
that women have have a film that for the
most part has quite a lot of male
characters in it but that they feel
kind of
comfortable and protected in that
environment you know
i agree with the christmas thing
it's much easier i think billy and i
talk about the christmas thing than than
the female thing but that's fantastic
that that that seems to be true
the films came out around christmas
i think a lot of people remember going
to the cinema at christmas and then
maybe around the christmas period
talking about oh we just went to see
fellowship and they did this and then
and then they have a big christmas party
oh they went to return they get oh you
saw it too oh wasn't it
so i think
tv channels
tend to do a little kind of lord of the
rings flight you know it's like
fellowship christmas eve two towers
christmas day and then the day after
maybe recently the king so
i know a lot of people get in touch with
me
throughout the christmas period and
there seems to be a bigger kind of jump
up in the interest of of lord the rings
around the christmas period um
and then finally
aragon's quite sexy isn't he yeah
objectively sexy yeah
men and women but you're talking about
women there there's there's almost a
kind of
like a classic archetypal male trope
within aragorn you know like
he'll protect you he'll look after you
he'll do the right thing
he'll go above and beyond to help his
friends and to and to do the noble thing
and maybe that carries with it some some
classic masculinity and maybe with all
of this
weird stuff that's going on between the
the fights between the sexes maybe the
simplification of those characters is
something that we that we yearn for a
little bit you know
um
yeah and then orlando bloom and as well
i mean you could spend just days
couldn't you just doing each other's
hair
they're lovely lovely
i've not supposedly someone said told me
that he's been pumping himself up
recently someone said have you seen
orlando bloom online and i thought it
was another one of those moments on the
no
on the paddleboard
you know no it wasn't but i suppose he's
pumped himself up chris
and is he yeah is he lifting weights
yeah so maybe we should billy and i are
going for dinner tonight with our other
hobbity cousins and maybe we'll pass a
phone around that includes recent images
of elijah of orlando bloom's buddy
should we do one last question one last
question well there's a lot of people
pick one how are you going to pick i'll
go which is a lot of pointing to
different people i think i'll go to the
well the thing is i went to the front of
the room the front of the room so i'm
going to go to the back sorry
i'm going to go to the back
one
two
three there's a jolly rancher there if
anyone so here's the jolly rancher six
we're going all the way to the back hey
go
[Music]
um and i am wondering when the drive
shaft concert is starting because i'm
ready to go oh you're wearing a
driveshaft t-shirt that's a tv show that
i did billy called lost i remember and
might i said am i allowed to say we can
say whatever you want i bet i don't know
what it is yeah what i did last week oh
go on hang on we'll come back thanks now
some of you might remember dominic
monahan from a movie a movie tv show
called lost now
[Applause]
there is a new tv show
called moonhaven oh
and we went to see the first episode
last week tom didn't watch it he left
went for a cup of tea
i sat and watched it
ladies and gentlemen
i found your new favorite tv show really
loved it moon haven is brilliant and
this guy is fantastic and it is such an
interesting character thanks really
cook yourself some second breakfast
and enjoy the artistic musings of mr
dominic monahan on the moon it's on amc
plus i brought billy as my day
it was great fun and like billy said i
ran off to have a cup of tea and i came
back and i thought billy's perfect for
this because you like sci-fi don't you i
love sci-fi but when i'm taken out as a
date i like the person who stay with me
yeah sorry about that
so i didn't like that part about to do
some talking about stuff but the the um
the kind of tagline above the show
says the future is better and what i
like about this show moonhaven is they
think about a world
in which the future has improved humans
have actually figured stuff out and then
crazy stuff happens so when are we going
to see a drive shaft well
what did you play in that again like
bass bass guitar bass guitar so i could
be the guitarist roger deacon from queen
yeah you could i was actually when i was
doing lost when when lost was a big show
um i was asked by a few pretty big bands
if i wanted to kind of come on and
support them you know play a song or two
and i was like look that's a that's a
brilliant offer
but
the song that i sang you all everybody
is really only a line
and there's no second verse and there's
only really a chorus so i was like i
just come on for like
and that's it
you know and that yeah you all everybody
and that came from
we didn't have the song we were on set
and there was a scene where myself and
matthew and evie were walking through a
field and i had to say to evie's
character i'm i'm
a in a band have you not heard of
driveshaft and she goes no and and
matthew's character goes now and i go
you all everybody and they both look at
me like no and i go
i'm very famous in certain circles now
that came from we didn't have the line
on the day we didn't have it we didn't
know what we're going to do and i i was
just kind of saying i'll maybe just hum
along to something
and there's a there's a episode of maury
povich who was a kind of
jerry springer almost type guy not quite
as shocking as jerry springer that type
of guy and
jj and brian burke
used to love this one episode of maury
povich where they would
you know have someone on stage and then
the audience would respond and some lady
in the audience stood up and was talking
about the guy on stage and she said to
him
you all everybody acting like you're the
stupid people wearing expensive clothes
and they just thought what an amazing
piece of gibberish that is that just
makes
complete non-sequitur and they were like
sing that so when i sang it in the show
in that scene i kind of sang it falsetto
as the as the harmony and then they
wrote the song backwards from that
so there you go
amazing now that is good info
and info that i never had yeah so thank
you for that there's a lot of stuff up
here bills i just keep in my brain have
we got now we've got time we've only got
20 minutes left right time for a riddle
we've got to eat the world we can't we
can do a riddle because we don't have
the answers
hold on till i tell you this
uh sean and elijah are organizing dinner
for us later you know meeting them late
for dinner so sean aston has said i'm in
the lobby to you know elijah
and said is that where we're meeting and
elijah's like yeah yeah well i'll come
down and then we'll just walk to the
restaurant and sean aston says
we have some experience in walking and
then he did a little volcano emoji
ah
sweet the mythology continues quite
funny there sean
hey john let's do a riddle let no let's
just let's do a tongue twister sorry
it's confusing life it's very confusing
this was a tongue twister that was sent
to us
um actually i didn't write this down
it's on your phone this is a good tongue
twister can we bring it up on screen
please do we have it
yeah we've got it don't worry about that
now it's a long one guys so we're only
going to do it once who's good at tongue
twisters in here because we always we
need somebody to be a judge i know
ours from the audience
who's good who's good this lady's been
aggressively pointed aggressively
pointed out so you are the judge okay
oh
we'll see if that's true by the end of
this so me me and dom will try it first
you tell us if we do it correctly
you're the judge we're only going to go
through it once you get three times to
get it right
and then you've got to try and beat the
best score what was your name
and where'd you come from
janet jan
jan g-e-n
from colorado springs s-p-r-i-n-g-s
brilliant who's going first
who's on first you we could we could do
it go on who should we try that now oh
no we shouldn't who's the baseball
player on first base well it's uh brian
jones see is that even funny
you go first tom really
ready give you a three two one and then
the timer will begin
hang on hang on all right
okay hammer time ready yeah three two
one go betty botter bought some butter
but she said this butter's bitter but if
i put my batter it will off taters
taters
sorry
john will have some work to do there it
made me sweat that yeah i saw that okay
and again
three two one go betty butter bought
some butter but she said this butter's
bitter if i put it in my butter ah
it's not an easy one
i can do it thank you thank you audience
take a breath take a breath a little bit
right three two
okay three two one go betty butter
bought some butter but she said this
butter's bitter if i put it in my batter
it will make my batter bitter but a bit
of better butter will make my batter
better then she bought a bit of butter
better than the bitter butter made her
bitter batter better so it was better
betty butter bought a bit of better
butter
19 seconds
dom you will never win
we don't even need to check that that
was perfect
last one
okay
we're getting a thumbs up from jen right
good
okay jen i shall do it thusly keep your
ears peel
you want three two one bills yes please
are you going on go or are you going on
one see when you go one
what i'll go on the zero after the one
three two one
and then now i'll go there not on the
one
oh that means you're going on the zero
then right what shall thank you say
three two one zero no don't do the zero
because i'll be saying betty
zero okay
johnny you ready
here we go
bills yes
three two one
betty botter bought some butter but she
said this butter's bitter if i were to
put it in the batter
[Laughter]
sorry we have to be very strict guys tom
i'm actually stretching my thigh just
yeah actually it looks very good for
your back tom yeah you don't get to see
sorry but jan she he did say were didn't
he
but dom's not allowed to say right jack
oh jen
don't let me down jen
joe let me just
jan
tom's not allowed to say right he can't
stop it
only jan can stop it all right jan if he
messes up loud loud show i'll keep going
something jan just your show butter
butter
hey there we go give you bring my leg
down
ready something's fell out your pocket
there oh
you can tell he used to be in a bend
go ready three two one betty butter
bought some butter but she said
no said she
[Laughter]
last go no pressure boyd
you should be good at this because
you're billy boy that's bees
that's alliteration
i'm not going to go for speed i'm going
to go for accuracy yeah yeah go for
clarity you ready hold on
everything out of his pockets cash
cash ready go down here we go
three two one
betty butter bought some butter but said
she this butter's bitter if i put it in
my batter it will make my batter bitter
but a bit of better butter will make my
batter better then she bought a bit of
butter better than the bitter butter
made her bitter butter better so it was
better betty bought a bought a bit of
better butter 22 seconds
[Applause]
still the champion
still the champion break free
i think i think we should i think we
should hear from jan if jan's saying
john
do you like to do your tongue twisters
with one leg upon a chair
[Laughter]
is that okay can i squeeze back
i'm doing the tyler durden thing i'll
try to work out if i give you my watch
out exterior oh my crutch are you ready
jen okay but i'm gonna say the way i
learned it okay it doesn't matter she's
gonna
oh she's slightly cheating
okay you're ready but wait for the zero
after the one you're you're doing the
three two one right right here we go jan
done right no pressure you get three
chances
three got it
jan you've gotta wait for the three two
one and then it's uh there won't be a
good story guys sorry
especially to you sir
yeah
that's quite nice it's lovely yeah
actually
yeah it's quite comfy sorry
ready jen
three two one
betty potter butter the butter was
better betty bought a better butter to
make the bitter butter taste better
i mean he's good but it's not that i
mean try that jan come on try that okay
sorry can we get a zero on the clock
again five seconds that was incredible
all right jen
give us a three two one jan here it
comes are you ready when i get after one
there won't be anything and then you say
betty okay
three two one
ready but buddy bought some butter but
we're gonna go again
again jan
it's not anarchy see the old ones
ingrained in your brain you see
three two one
betty bott's better better
absolutely it's impossible
jan no pressure
right no wait
three two one
betty botta bought some butter but she
said cheetahs butter's bitter if i put
in my batter it will make my batter
bitter but a bit of better butter will
make my batter better then she bought a
bit of butter better butter better than
the bitter butter made her bitter batter
better so it was better betty bada
bought a bit of better butter i'm
getting it i'm getting it
17 seconds
17 seconds what do you think of that
well
can i be nitpicky no okay in that case
perfect if you think anything that jan
learned that when she was four years old
and she learnt it a different way i mean
that's it's difficult to change it in
your brain
hey bills what should we eat the world
let's eat the world
billy and dom eat the world
now
is there anyone out there that wants to
have a jolly rancher and doesn't have
one or does everyone seem to have a
jolly rancher you don't have one someone
in the back there
can someone pass a jolly rancher lovely
capped gentleman in the back there
could we get those gummy ones we have
gummy good jolly ranch thank you my dear
oh is there gummy ones can we get
they're coming in they're coming in
guys i'm just gonna start by saying
jolly ranchers first appeared in 1949
when bill and dorothy
harmson
founded the jolly rancher company they
originally only sold products to give
the kids living in the area around
denver colorado
harmson purposely gave his company the
friendliest name imaginable we'll talk
about that because is it i don't know
the friendliest name imaginable so it
was appealing as possible to consumers
at the time the dollar the jolly rancher
company sold chocolates and ice cream in
addition to the hard candies but clearly
one was more popular than the others ice
cream wasn't very popular in colorado
because it's freezing
so harmson decided to focus on hard
candies because they were so popular
they're year round so let's everybody
suck on a jolly rancher everyone enjoy a
jolly rancher now i didn't realize that
these were a uh denver colorado staple
but welcome a lot of people didn't know
they come in classic flavors blue
raspberry green apple cherry grape and
watermelon is there an overwhelmingly
kind of popular
flavor out there
anarchy anarchy in the audience there
dog here what are you hearing what is
the main flavors well there's blue
raspberry okay apple which i heard is
universally disliked
no says some of the audience
when dom says
a flavor we want to hear a yes okay okay
we'll start with this
blue raspberry
it's a big one it's a good start bills
green apple
that was bigger
cherry
[Applause]
grape
disliked i actually got a boo it got boo
and finally watermelon
oh my goodness don't bring me a
watermelon immediately
i've got blue i've got a blue
uh raspberry i'm sucking on a cherry
address um the watermelon you say
lots of chicken
right hold on here i'll keep going you
you get into that the hershey company
expanded the range of jolly ranchers to
include the same delicious flavours in
lollipops drinks jelly beans cherry
candy sour candy gummy candy candy cane
she can even find jolly rancher pillows
shirts and lip glosses i love lip gloss
no i do genuinely and
in fact my one of my number one hangover
cures if i happen to have had
uh one or two glasses of wine too many
is lip balm i won't
try and be too far away well i mean kind
of because i put it all over my lips i
get very chapped lips when i'm hungover
that's true
topped it from here watermelon is very
very good
what are you sucking on
well that was a cherry one but i like
gummies you know me i like coming i'm
gonna try a gummy
watermelon
as um we hear this story dumb go on in
new york
one time
the cops arrested a couple of guys for
carrying what the cops thought was
crystal meth
after testing it they found out the
crystal meth was actually blue raspberry
jolly rancher candies
but that must mean that those guys they
weren't just walking around they didn't
get arrested for just that they must
have put it in some little naughty bag
and crushed it he probably was just
sitting
sitting on his on his jolly rancher all
day and accidentally made it look like
crystal meth
breaking bad
the watermelon's fantastic oh i'm gonna
have a watermelon
i i associate hard candy with road trips
does anyone else you know like road
trips with your mom and dad and stuff so
they kind of slightly make me feel a
little
sick and it's not but it stops you
feeling sick i think that's why the mum
and dad hey
let's give it some scores come on really
flavor
well there's many flavors isn't that
we'll go for your best flavor which
would be watermelon i'm gonna put
watermelon in my mouth right now i'm
gonna swap it for the grape again to see
how i feel i'll tell you what we'll do
as well guys
what we'll do in case you're interested
when you leave we'll pour all these out
and if anyone does want to take
jolly ranchers with them they can
flavour for watermelon bills what do you
think well i'm gonna go absolutely the
grape bear
i like the grape better than the
watermelon
there we go we've got a believer
and i'm gonna say
as a flavor thom
i'm gonna give it a 9.4 wow
you loved it i really like that
i'm enjoying a watermelon one now mm-hmm
it's good
i'm gonna give it
an eight point one
i hate playing white that's all right
what about aesthetics how does it look
classic it's a classic rainbow flavor
but as a kid growing up you and you
growing up in scotland me growing up in
england we weren't exposed to jolly
ranchers as kids were they so for me
this is like a piece of americana this
is america it is it's as it's as an
american as like a can of coke
or you know uh a couple of dog or
something like that so and i love
america i love living here it's a
beautiful country so
the way that he looks classic i'm giving
it a
i'm gonna give it an 8.6 out of 10 for
lux that's good because i like the look
of it as well it looks like there's a
lot of chemicals in it but i don't mind
yeah
and as you know it's only organs that
create chemicals in the body as you
learn tonight
um well it contains red 40 blue one
yellow five yellow six and the final uh
ingredient in uh
jolly ranchers is
limonene and who knows what limonene is
does it have any e102 there's no e
numbers in it no
um
for the way it looks dom
i'm i'm giving it an 8.9 you're liking
this a lot i like swapping them out
and then billy's favorite category
usefulness how useful how useful is it
like can you crunch it up and fill the
cups um
i'm sorry can you crunch it up what do
you do when you crunch it up somebody
said yes there what do you do
all right put it around the cake you
could sprinkle it on ice cream right i'm
sure there's ice cream parlors
put it in a slushie says our friend in
the order see if you crunch it up and
put it around the cake does it not
become sharp
is it i mean you think you would i mean
imagine you with a hangover with dry
lips
and a jolly rancher cake
but i do like the idea of you know like
an ice cream cone and then you dip it in
jolly ranchers smashed up stuff like
class
the other great yeah
well
if we were doing like bare knuckle
fighting
put it in like which we probably will do
at some point
and then jolly ranchers
and then we'd punch each other like
broken glass oh it's like a sweet punch
but if you were coming at me i would i
would lick you
and i'd get some grape just before you
hit me yeah
brilliant so yeah it could be a very
useful a minor weapon
also i like the fact that the hard candy
you can put in your pocket for the rest
of the day and it's not going to melt
and turn into a mess in your pocket so
quite useful put them in your glove
boxes for times where you're needing a
little anything else anyway
substitution right that'd be good yeah
the cough
helps with dry mouth dry mouth for older
patients
i've heard that before
there you go
yes
you can soak it in vodka says someone in
the audience and then you get a jolly
rancher infused shot i'll get a bottle
of smelling off for tonight john
bring them back
i'm well in that case i'm going to say
very useful i'm going to give it a score
9.7
hey i mean there's a there's about 10
uses that have been called out there i'm
going to give it a high one as well jump
hang on a second sir
exactly you do run the risk of going to
prison for 10 to 15 years yes
every time you have a blue one so never
have a blue one when you're in new york
bills 9.2 you loved it that's a very
high score for you there and never ever
buy a jolly rancher i won't i almost
choked to death there by the way
[Laughter]
that's another use for it if you you
know
i would have given you the heimlich hey
you guys don't know this story but billy
uh one time saved my life by kind of
giving me the heimlich one time in a
restaurant yeah we were out for dinner
in london
yeah
saved my life wasn't that amazing
we're out for dinner in london
i showed up about five minutes late
and everyone had started eating and i
was starving and i was wolfing down this
food and i think it was i think it was
shrimp toast i think it was a shrimp
toast yeah which is always embarrassing
when you think that's what's i've been
in a few situations where i've thought
i'm almost dead and the overwhelming
experience or feeling is wow this is
really embarrassing
this is really embarrassing what an
embarrassing way to die anyway
i tried to swallow this mouth full of
shrimp toast or prawn toast as they
called down down in london and it kind
of went half down in half up and i was
like oh interesting sensation
and realized that i couldn't breathe and
i thought that's okay don't make a fuss
everyone's having a chat no one's
noticed so i tried to swallow again down
up and then i thought hmm
not going down not going up just kind of
sitting in stasis and laughing at me
billy's wife was sat next to me i turned
to billy's wife couldn't speak obviously
and i was going like this and billy's
going well you choking you joking
and i was going mm-hmm i am choking i am
young i'm young tears running down my
face tears running down my face
ali didn't really do anything did he did
it was a [ __ ] she moment billy
shot into action i did jumped up ran
around me while i was sat down and just
whacked me really hard in the back i
never
flew out
absolutely
[Music]
yeah and that could happen with the
jolly rancher i'm absolutely happy with
the jolly rancher and we didn't really
talk a huge amount about it because it
wasn't it caused a bit of a scene at the
table wouldn't it you were sweating i
mean like his his
shirt was sweet yeah yeah and when it
dries out it wasn't just the prawn toast
that flew out a bit of sputum kind of
came out as well and that kind of went
down my chin and i was like i'm fine now
guys
wiping it down the tablecloth but he did
save my life so thanks thanks for saving
no worries
well that was high scores for the jolly
ranchers though high scores for the
jelly ranchers we'll leave these on the
table for you guys guys we've run out of
time we get we're gonna have to go but
thanks for coming i don't know if you
guys are here
over the convention weekend saturday and
sunday
hopefully we see you all at the hobbit
panel
we've got a few surprises in store
haven't we oh yeah it's good it's going
to be a great weekend thank you for
coming out to the friendship onion today
it's really fun so much that we didn't
get to honestly it goes fast yes ah you
guys are cool
thank you very much
see you at the next we'll see this onion
thanks for coming
bye
take this big bag of jolly ranchers if
you want it
[Music]
with me and hold me tight all through
the night you're shining bright i'm your
oyster baby on my pearl